foreign
let's run out to Kimberly in Atlanta
Georgia what's up Kimberly
hey I'm glad to hear that you're well
caffeinated this morning because I'm
very sleepy I am borderline messed so
we're I mean I'm real close what's up
so my husband and I've been married for
about 25 years and I'm just trying to
determine
how we can maintain our I guess marital
Health in the fact that we no longer
really can sleep in the same bed
together at night because he makes so
much noise and I'm a very light sleeper
and so I feel so guilty that we're not
sharing the same bed every night but I
don't really know what the right answer
is
oh so this is this is like a contentious
conversation in the nerd World
um so
talk to me about the conversation Jill
had to get to this point it well so you
know he obviously feels horrible that
you know he keeps me awake because of
you know whatever sounds you know
snoring or even just like Breathing
heavily or whatever that he makes
um I want to lean in right there I want
to lean in right there
he feels awful and yeah I literally had
a conversation with somebody a few days
ago a buddy of mine
and I said and I quote and again this is
a very particular person with a very
particular set of circumstances I said
I'll put a thousand dollars on the table
that if you cut out grains and sugars
for 60 to 90 days you're you're snoring
an apnea would would curb dramatically
and he looked at me and he goes I know
you're exactly right
and so when you tell me
um he feels terrible about it my next
question is always how terrible terrible
enough to to go to a sleep doctor
terrible enough to start changing things
and start trying things or just terrible
like I feel bad
just right back to it
I mean you know I think he'd be willing
to go have a sleep study done we
actually did talk about that just like a
month or so ago and he said he'd be open
to it
um and it's not even so much snoring
it's just he's a very loud breather at
night like he's a mouth breather nice
and I'm such a light sleeper that the
slightest sounds wake me up so then I
feel like it's my fault because I don't
you know I'm I'm just too sensitive so
it's just been it's just been a funny
thing that's been going on for with us
for like the last couple years okay so
here's oh I
there's nothing nothing hotter like
erotically than looking over at an open
mouth to mouth breather right there's
half it was like cash to the world and
it's just
oh man yeah
um and Okay so
that's probably a picture none of us
needed in our heads so
um I it is funny and also I'm gonna make
it a little more serious is that cool
yes all right so serious number one
um I would be willing to bet again I
don't have a lot but I'd be willing to
bet that he is not sleeping continuously
for more than four hours a night and
maybe tosses and turns and gets a five
or six or seven I would love love love
for him to go get a Garmin watch and
just begin tracking a sleep
hmm okay because almost no I'll say
almost always
a significant amount of the time there
is underlying pathologies underlined and
it can be as simple as as it is in my
case which is uh for some reason I got
some weird food allergies that my body
just does weird things so in my house
um my wife we have a very similar
Dynamic except
um I have a wife who's a that was a
researcher and so she began to just
quietly track
what because some nights I would snore
and some nights I would sleep like she
would have to reach over and touch my
chest because she thought I died in my
sleep I was just so out and
um
she began to track it and she landed on
three things beer pizza and candy
period and if I have those three things
I will snore for some reason my body
swells does something on the inside and
I used to try to dig out the physiology
I don't care anymore what I know is
those three things are to be true are
true and when I went and started
tracking my sleep first with a woop
strap and then with the this garment I
wear now
um by the way I've got no affiliation
with either of those companies they just
Garmin is just a tremendous product
um
I noticed that my sleep was was
deleterious on those nights like it was
it was half of what it normally is
and so now I know
one thing to be true
if I do and if I have a beer with some
buddies if I have some pizza or if I eat
some candy I am making a conscious
choice to snore
I'm also making a conscious noise to
sleep in another bedroom
I'm also making a conscious decision to
not sleep very well
and I occasionally do that because my
time with my friends or my wife or my
family or whatever's going on it's worth
that trade but it is very much in my
life very much an either or and that's
simply because I got so curious number
one number two my wife got curious
number three I took very seriously the
fact that I was disrupting her life in
that in that way
yeah and so I think your husband like
sounds like he likes the idea
of you having a good night's sleep but
not enough to just go all in
because I got I got insane about it
yeah I think he just thinks that it's
something he can't control yeah with him
that there is maybe something that can
be done about it a whole bunch it
actually does eat pretty healthy but at
the same time I'm sure that I could
start looking at it and tracking it just
to see if there is because it's like you
said it's not every night some nights he
sleeps great and I can stay put and then
other nights you know he's just ripping
and roaring and I'm like I'm going to
the other bedroom again I'm not a sleep
study guy I'm a sleep study expert
um
I I would be willing to bet there's some
some sort of allergic reaction side of
him and I say allergies I'm speaking
very Loosely they're not in a clinical
sense in any way but all it says is
here's where there's there's a big
discussion back and forth in the nerd
World there are some studies that say
over the long haul that sleeping in
separate beds does disrupt your sex life
it does disrupt your intimacy life and
it might even have some Downstream
Health consequences and there's some
other studies that say
Above All Else get a good night's sleep
nothing in your life matters
um nothing nothing you can do in your
life matters if it's built on a
foundation of less than good sleep
and so in my house and I again this is
one of those like there's no consensus
in the literature so I'm just gonna tell
you what I do
um probably one night a week maybe two
I'll sleep another room
because I've made some dumb Choice
um maybe yeah that's not true maybe once
every two weeks I will I'll go sleep in
the guest room
yeah and it's it's a gift for her it's a
gift for me I also know about once a
month maybe twice a month I will I'll
know about eight o'clock like oh man I'm
gonna be up to four I don't know why my
buddy does that it just does and I used
to fight it and fight it and fight it in
Medicaid I just don't fight it at all
anymore I just get a lot of work done
it's great and I make sure I do my
workouts
um early that next morning and then my
body just adjusts itself and so I don't
fight it anymore and but what is
important is I want to make sure
um at least one of us is sleeping good
so I make sure she gets some sleep and
she'll tell you right
um she does not sleep when I'm snoring
and she sleeps at a different level when
I'm in and in the same bed
and my guess is you experience that I'm
missing that's right because you know we
used to have that and you know I love
that closeness and you know just that
security feeling so I it's just been
hard because then like I said I feel
guilty when I'm not sleeping in there
that I'm like oh I'm shunning you or
whatever so that's that's good right now
the greatest gift you could give your
husband is a well-rested you
yeah the greatest gift he could give you
is to really dig in and figure out why
his body has begun acting the way it has
been over the last few
um months years
um I think it's a formal sleep study is
great I think before you would pay the
money to go do a formal sleep study I
think it would be fun just to track
I think it'd be fun just to track and so
here's how this would look in your house
you go ahead and set up the guest room
as though you're gonna sleep in there
and then you get ready and go to bed
and if he wakes you up in the middle of
the night you all have written down what
y'all ate the night before
and it might be as simple as that
it might also be as simple as a meeting
coming up that he had or didn't have I
would look at the simplest things first
and I would do anything
to not have pizza and
a dark beer and Candy slash chips and
queso I would do anything for those four
things not to affect my body in that way
but they do they do and they don't
affect my friends in that same way which
is super annoying but they do
and ask me choosing reality I gotta live
in that so you are not a bad person
you're not your marriage isn't falling
apart all those none of that stuff is
true those are all stories that we got
from Leave it to Beaver right
um I don't even know why I said Leave it
to Beaver but if you are new to the
world that shows about a thousand years
old but what's important is you all
decide
I want to sleep in the same bed as you
you want to sleep in the same bed as me
that means we have to get to the bottom
of this we have to figure it out and
let's get very curious and very aware of
what's going on and then if we can't
figure that out and over the next two
weeks this doesn't take a long time like
this is this is a couple of weeks then
let's go get a formal sleep study let's
go figure that out let's go see if
there's something with jaw alignment or
with the way my my pillow work I mean
there's any number of things
um but almost always underneath like a
sudden and I say the last couple years a
sudden snoring sudden deep breathing you
start heading into sleep apnea that
waking up and go to sleep waking up
going to sleep you're getting into some
underlying pathology that your body's
just trying to get your attention about
and it's just good go get checked out
it's good we'll get it checked out but
this all starts with you sitting on your
husband saying I've been getting some
sleep but I miss you
would you be willing to not just talk
about it but let's get very very serious
about figuring out
what's happening to your body at night
and let's see if we can figure that out
and it might cost you uh your nightly
ball of ice cream but it might cost you
that glass of wine it might cost you
whatever
but am I worth it
don't do that that would be mean but I
mean also do that